did nas know he wanted to do a firm
reunion record
like did he come to you and say hey dude
i want to get everybody back together or
did the beat kind of speak to him in
that way
nah he had he uh we had to join he had
did his part
and um i just was like man we should get
a z on this [ __ ]
and as i told him once and
he was like okay for sure and then i uh
we played the song again i was like yo
let's get a z on this [ __ ] and he was
like you serious
i'm like for sure sent it to him dude
body that [ __ ]
and he was like yo i'm about to just
throw the rest of the homies on there
and then after that
he um he just i guess he linked with dre
just like on some regular [ __ ] for them
to chop it
and he ended up playing the joint and
dre hop throwing that [ __ ] right
there
yeah even to hear cormega on a song with
nas again it's so crazy because they
have like that
big falling out and cormega's so fire
yeah for sure
they all bodied it man foxy foxy of
course did
was there ever any um attempt to try to
get nature on on the record
not that i know of okay because i mean
nature's the only guy from the firm that
was missing
or um shout out to nature um and then
dre
was probably the last piece i'm assuming
right now yeah he was he was the last
piece
added that's crazy like dogs hit you
like yo dre
yeah he's on the [ __ ] what movie
fire that [ __ ] crazy bro